POLLS ON HOW AMERICANSEEL W CNN
ABOUT THE STATE OF AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY AND WHETHER THEY TRUST
THE ELECTION SYSTEMS.
THE RESULTS ARE CONCERNING.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO CNN'S SENIOR
DATA REPORTER.
HARRY, CNN IS ASKING HOW
CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT THE
ELECTIONS SHOW THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE OVER THE LAST YEAR.
HOW HAS THAT NUMBER EVOLVED?
>> YOU SAID CONCERNING, I WOULD
ARGUE DEPRESSING.
WE ESSENTIALLY ASKED HOW
CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT THESE
ELECTIONS WILL REFLECT THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE.
IF YOU LOOK BACK IN 2021 IN
JANUARY, WHAT YOU SAW WAS A
MAJORITY SAID THAT THEY WERE
CONFIDENT THAT ELECTIONS
REFLECTED THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE, 59%.
BUT THAT DROPPED TO 48% IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2021 AND NOW IT'S
JUST 44% SAY YES, THE MAJORITY
NOW SAY NO AT 56%.
SO VERY DEPRESSING.
BUT I THINK WHAT'S ALSO
INTERESTING IS THE GROUPS THAT
HAVE CHANGED.
SO I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT MUCH
OF A SURPRISE THAT REPUBLICANS
FEEL THAT ELECTIONS DON'T
REFLECT THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT OUR POLL
HAS SHOWED.
BUT COMPARE THAT TO BACK IN
JANUARY OF 2021.
YOU CAN SEE THAT REPUBLICANS
HAVE STAYED THE SAME, NOT
CONFIDENT THAT U.S. ELECTIONS
REFLECT THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
AT 74%.
BUT DEMOCRATS AND DEMOCRATIC
LEANERS, ONLY 13% IN JANUARY OF
TW
2021 SAID THEY WERE NOT
CONFIDENT.
THAT HAS JUMPED 20 POINTS TO
33%.
NOW IT'S NOT JUST THE MAJORITY
OF REPUBLICANS THAT ARE NOT
CONFIDENT, IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL
PORTION OF DEMOCRATS WHO ARE NOT
CONFIDENT AS WELL.
>> RIGHT.
WELL, TWO THINGS HAVE HAPPENED
SINCE THEN.
THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
EFFORTS BY STATES TO MAKE IT
TOUGHER TO VOTE AND, TWO, YOU'VE
HAD A LOT OF DEMOCRAT
POLITICIANS SAYING THAT THIS IS
THE NEW JIM CROW ERA, A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS BAD MOUTHING ELECTIONS
IN ADDITION TO THOSE NEW
RESTRICTIVE LAWS.
WHAT ROLE, THOUGH, DO YOU THINK
JANUARY 6 HAS IN THE PUBLIC
SENTIMENT?
WILL THE COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING
THE INSURRECTION, WILL IT HELP
OR WILL IT HURT THIS PROBLEM?
>> I THINK IT MIGHT HELP A
LITTLE BIT, RIGHT?
ESSENTIALLY IF YOU ASK FOLKS HOW
THEY FEEL ABOUT THE JANUARY 6
COMMISSION, COMMITTEE, IS IT
GOING TO BE A FAIR ESSENTIALLY
HEARING, WHAT WE DO SEE IS THAT
THE PLURALITY DO SAY, YES, IT'S
GOING TO BE A FAIR
INVESTIGATION.
36% SAY IT'S A ONE-SIDED EFFORT
TO BLAME TRUMP.
AND THEN THERE'S 20% WHO SAY
THEY HAVEN'T HEARD ENOUGH.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS WHO
REALLY AREN'T PAYING SO MUCH
ATTENTION TO A LOT OF THIS
STUFF.
I THINK IF YOU ALSO ESSENTIALLY
LOOK AT HOW PEOPLE THINK THAT
THE COMMITTEE AND THEIR FINDINGS
MAY IN FACT HELP, WILL IT HELP
STRENGTHEN DEMOCRACY, WHAT WE
SEE IN OUR POLL IS THAT ONLY 37%
SAY IT'S LIKELY THAT THE SELECT
COMMITTEE WILL HELP TO PROTECT
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
THE CLEAR MAJORITY EITHER
BELIEVE NO, IT WILL NOT HELP OR
13% SAY JANUARY 6 NOT A PROBLEM.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THOSE FOLKS
ARE, BUT THEY'RE OUT THERE.
>> HALF THE PEOPLE BELIEVES
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IS UNDER
ATTACK.
WHO EXACTLY ARE THESE PEOPLE?
>> PEOPLE LIKE ME.
PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO ARE YOUNG.
FOLKS IN MY GENERATION JUST
DON'T GET IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT OUR POLL, THERE
IS JUST SUCH A LARGE AGE GAP
HERE.
WHO BELIEVED DEMOCRACY WAS UNDER
ATTACK?
JUST 31% OF THOSE AGE 18 TO 34.
FOLKS LIKE MY MOTHER, 77% AGE 65
AND OVER BELIEVE THAT DEMOCRACY
IS UNDER ATTACK.
THIS IS ABOUT AS LARGE OF AN AGE
GAP AS I'VE SEEN ON ANY
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
ALSO I THINK THIS IS REALLY
INTERESTING.
IF YOU ASK FOLKS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY BELIEVE DEMOCRACY IS UNDER
ATTACK AND YOU GO ESSENTIALLY BY
WHETHER OR NOT THEY THINK THAT
THE 2020 ELECTION WAS
LEGITIMATE, 69% OF THOSE WHO
THOUGHT THAT BIDEN'S WIN WAS NOT
LEGITIMATE, THEY BELIEVE THAT
DEMOCRACY IS UNDER ATTACK.
JUST 42% OF THOSE WHO THINK
BIDEN LEGITIMATELY WON BELIEVE
DEMOCRACY IS UNDER ATTACK.
I THINK THAT REALLY JUST GOES
AGAINST THE GRAIN BECAUSE YOU
WOULD THINK THAT THOSE WHO
BELIEVED THAT BI